les chéris bon j'ai des cadeaux pour
vous bien sûr il ya les visiteurs qui
vont dire de voir dans un instant j'ai
amené des cadeaux pour tout le monde
je vous le dis je voulais donner dans un
instant le voyez là d'autant que j'ai
payé moi même on va coûter une tonne
cette affaire
[Applaudissements]
regardez ce que je vous ai ramené à tout
ça alors là là vous dire j'ai d'autres
cadeaux il y aura toute la semaine des
cadeaux pour les gars
avec vos initiales alors j'en ai même
même si vous êtes parti je vous en ai
pris un regarder le nom le lourd pour
tirer les lois merci il ya le ya le
alors il ya logique
le gie jean-luc away jean-luc imac ou
tee shirts qui est le jdle
alors j'ai pris de colo j je sais pas
bien passé c'est déjà bien il ya un
autre gît rien de julien courbet général
ouais mais il est pas là tant pis je
vais avant la le gie a gagné mes chéris
le chef et qui loge et gilles verdez le
rer
vous étiez c'est vous qui les hébergent
[Rires]